Oh, I booked us a table tonight at Carluccio's for 7.
Oh, that's nice. We like it at Carluccio's, don't we?
I'll grab that.
Stern!
Can I help you?
It's me, Tel. Your friend.
I'm sorry, I don't know you.
We've been friends for years.
We went to school together, remember?
I'm sorry, I think you have the wrong flat.
Oh, come on, Stern, you must remember.
All the nights out we had, the holidays, all the drinking?
Look, remember this?
This is us. It's me and you.
That's me.
I look happy.
Tel!
Yes, Stern, that's me.
Tel, what's happened to me?
Why am I wearing a cardigan, Tel?
I hate cardigans.
What's going on with me?
I don't understand.
I'm so scared.
It's okay, Stern.
All the boys are going out tonight and you're coming with us.
Joel, these shirts need folding.
I'm sorry, Tel, I can't come out tonight.
There are some clothes that need folding.
Stern, no.
Goodbye, friend.